[Music]
all right um
real quick i want to talk about a
question i'm getting a lot and that is
how do i talk to my kids about war
how do i talk to my kids about what's
going on in russia and ukraine how do i
talk to my kids about what might happen
down the road with this with that
um and there's a lot of mumbo jumbo out
there and there's a lot of stuff that we
picked up because of the way our parents
talk to us about war about 9 11 or about
the invasion of iraq or afghanistan all
this
most of us just find ourselves with our
kids just doing what we were taught or
we hit the pendulum really far we start
googling stuff which is always a
disaster so i'm gonna spend a few
minutes talking about it
um
i have talked on this show and and let's
i'll just repeat it a little a little
bit if you missed it um
the
the russian invasion of ukraine that
messed me up that's hard for me um
for a number of reasons one of which is
i got a 12 year old boy and that 12 year
old little boy is about to be a teenager
i mean he's about to be 18 which means
he's about to
um
be right in the thick of stuff
i care about my communities i care about
my kids i care about the what's going on
to the ukrainian folks i care about
people all over the world who are
struggling
and
so i
and i've committed my life to being
honest with my kids and telling them the
truth and so here's a couple of things
that um i can give you that's going to
help you have these conversations in
your house
number one
your kids can only be as well as you are
they can only be as okay as you are
why is that important
if you're having another drink and
another drink or you have found yourself
just grabbing another bowl of ice cream
and another bag of cookies if you have
the news going 24 7 365 and you're angry
you're raged out you're just mad you're
yelling at the president because he
didn't do this or because he did do that
or that vice president
your kid is absorbing in real time
this is how you cope with things like
war
you yell and scream you throw your
stupid opinions around that are
highly uneducated because you're
filtering them through a news source or
your top secret twitter source whatever
it is
or some guy with a youtube channel who
has the real truth whatever it is your
kid is watching you to learn how to deal
with stuff when it gets stressful i just
eat some more just drink some more just
yell some more
or go lift weights whatever it is so
know in your head that you are modeling
behavior so what do you do number one
model good behavior
moder model healthy behavior actions
speak louder than words
what did this look like in my house
in my house
i
asked my son to come upstairs with me
and i shut the door and said hey we need
to have a serious talk
and he probably thought he was in
trouble and i said i need you to tell me
what you've been what you've been
hearing
so i didn't launch into a uh what what
have you been hearing about the war what
have you been hearing about russia we've
been hearing about ukraine all this i
didn't launch into
can you believe was i didn't do that
even though i have my opinions
i didn't um
you know
wait for two weeks for him to finally
stumble around to ask me a question i
went directly to him
i'm trying to model good behavior when
there's a hard conversation have we get
right in the middle of it we have the
hard conversation and the hard
conversations start by me asking him
what have you heard
what are you hearing at school and
shocker he's heard way more than i would
have thought
and his understanding is way more
screwed up than i would have thought
you know big shocker between what's
happening on the ground through news
sources through social media through
parents through sixth graders he's got a
screwed up story duh right
duh
model good behavior
listen be still
number two
my friend rachel cruz says this and i
love it
share don't scare have age-appropriate
conversations i have had a conversation
with my six-year-old daughter because
she's picking stuff up in kindergarten
had an age-appropriate conversation with
my son those conversations looked
different but i still had them
still important to have with my son
talked about
yes there's children
getting hurt in this deal there's adults
who had to hand their kids off
and then go back and fight
the idea of me
um
having to put you and mom and josephine
in a car and send you all away while me
and the neighbors
um got our guns
and fought for freedom and for our homes
the picture that's scary
and so i was pretty open with him i
didn't tell him oh they're coming for us
and the president sucks so bad and all
this
it's going to lead i didn't do any of
that because he's 12. had he been 18 i
would have had a harder conversation
about future about what a draft is about
um responsibilities
that would have been a different
conversation with a 16 17 or 18 year old
but he's 12
with my daughter i asked her how much
she had heard she'd hurt a little bit
and i said yeah there's some scary
things going on there's a country that's
um
being pretty ugly to another country
and people are getting hurt and it's
scary it makes daddy sad
and she said i'm sorry daddy i said yeah
so i'm honest and i'm open so share
don't scare
do
not hide this
and do not over sensationalize it to
your kids
find the right balance
and then here's the third thing
be honest about your grief
i looked at my 12 year old son and said
on the way to work i almost had to pull
over because i started crying i couldn't
stop
that's rare for me it happens once twice
a year i couldn't stop
big tough deloney
i got caught up in the thought of
passing my son off
the thought of the nobility and bravery
we're witnessing from people who are
saying you can't have my house you can't
have my home
my
my
a thousand years of my ancestors are
buried here i'm i'm staying
the
unbelievable response of poland and
germany some of these countries that are
stepping up and saying no no no you're
not gonna stay in a camp you're gonna
stay in my house
and they're showing up at these train
stations with signs saying i can take
a mom and two little kids
i can take um two adults and three
little kids
that's heroic that's heroism that's
strength but i talked to my kid about my
grief my sadness i told him that yeah
your daddy cried
and you know what he felt less alone
i said yes it's really scary because
once war spins up like this you don't
know how it ends
there's some unknowns
and then
i modeled here's what i do and when when
i'm grieving serve when things get
bonkers we serve
so let's go outside and we're going to
take a long long hike walk and we're
going to pick up trash in the trash tag
for our neighbors
we are going to
figure out places to donate we're going
to make sure that we're giving
a church we're going to make sure that
we are i want my kid to know here's
healthy outlets we're going to have to
go move her body dad's pretty stressed
out he's pretty worried about it and
i've been honest about ways i haven't
been healthy i've been on my phone more
the last 12 14 days than i have in the
last year if not two years
glued
and i had a conversation with my kids
last night my wife called me out on it i
had a conversation with them and said
guys i've been on my phone way too much
this this this war it's got me glued to
it and insert war with it happened
during hurricane harvey back in my
hometown i stayed glued to my phone and
i got unhealthy because of it
um any number of things the astros went
to the world series i got glued to my
phone unhealthy right so it happens
several times like i just get glued in
here and i need to apologize to my kids
and say this isn't what life is this
isn't healthy for me or for y'all and
i've chosen for a few days this phone
over y'all and i'm sorry
because i can get my information in 20
minutes and then turn it off
i get what i need in 10 or 15 minutes
i can get i've got some actual good
curated feeds i can get what i need and
i can turn it off and be done
and so real quick i'm gonna model
healthy behavior when something bad
happens something scary happens like war
i'm gonna look in the mirror first
and control me my thoughts my actions
what i'm eating what i'm drinking what
i'm saying how raged out i am and i'm
gonna take care of me i'm gonna model
healthy behaviors number two i'm gonna
share it on scare number three i'm gonna
be honest about my grief so that my kids
realize i'm a person that they're not
crazy for being scared too
i'm gonna give them honesty and then
we're gonna
demonstrate healthy behaviors what we're
gonna do next
that's it be honest with your kids
hold their hands touch their face don't
try to hide but turn off the tv they
don't need to be seeing bombs and
mothers carrying out children who passed
away they don't need to see any of that
stuff
be honest with them
and then get on to modeling healthy
behaviors